and the the intention wasn't all of a
sudden to have
uh the the talk about me running for
president again
dwayne johnson has set his sights on a
higher calling
but only if it's what the people want a
united country as we know is
is is its strongest and i want to see
that for our country
in a preview of his upcoming interview
on sunday today with willie geist
the 49-year-old actor revealed he's open
to running for president
i do have that goal to unite our country
and i also feel that if this is what the
people
want then i will do that
this new statement has fueled johnson's
latest round of political speculation
which was kicked off last week with a
poll from newsweek
the poll found that at least 46 percent
of americans
would support the actors presidential
campaign i just want to learn as much as
i possibly can
and i understand you're taking some
under the radar meetings to possibly run
for president
it's just really to understand more and
to learn more in 2018
johnson confirmed reports that he had
secretly taken meetings to consider
a potential campaign the idea of running
for president
has been very flattering that a good
amount of people have been wanting me to
run and
i honestly it's so flattering to become
president
that is a skill set that i feel like you
have to know
you know you have to put in the top like
years and years of service
so anyway that's where i'm at and in one
of those moments that make you go
only in hollywood johnson can already be
seen running for president
on tv anyway wayne johnson for the 2032
u.s presidential race are the people
ready
they are not ready but they need to see
it on johnson's new sitcom
young rock a fictional version of
himself is campaigning for the oval
office in 2032
nine years from now how did we get here
while johnson had been a guest speaker
at the gop convention in 2000
his political views took a back seat as
he focused on becoming a worldwide box
office star
where is our leader but in just the past
year johnson has broken his silence not
once
but twice beginning with this instagram
post where he spoke out against
president trump
and i am not the president of the united
states
but i am a man and i am a father who
cares so deeply about my family
about my children and the world that
they will live in
that's who i am i am
a man who is frustrated i'm disappointed
i'm angry then a few months later
johnson gave his official endorsement to
joe biden
and kamala harris is there going to be a
president johnson
look i think anything's possible right
this is america
in 2017 johnson revealed during an
interview with gq
that a presidential run was a real
possibility
and johnson told et he was humbled by
the positive response
but were you surprised how people ran
with it and said i like that idea
i got to tell you something kevin it was
it was really the
it was incredibly flattering i can tell
you i feel that
what people are responding to i think
with me is that i have a i do a pretty
good job
uh in terms of leadership and in terms
of galvanizing a lot of people and
bringing them together
to get a job done and to be better
but that's what a president does that is
it's one of the qualities yes of a
president